now taiwan says huge chinese military
drills appear to be a simulation of an
attack on the island beijing has
conducted some of its largest ever
maneuvers around taiwan this week u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taipei and get china which regards the
self-ruling island as its own territory
relations between beijing and washington
have no stive
as the alarmist sounded soldiers aboard
this destroyer in the waters off taiwan
immediately go into combat mode
within hours of nancy pelosi's visit
chinese missiles struck the seas north
south and east of taiwan
multiple war planes are also circling
the island of 23 million crossing the
demarcation line that divides the taiwan
strait an unofficial buffer zone between
china and taiwan and a major route for
vessels almost half the global container
fleet
nearly 90 percent of the world's largest
ships
passed through the taiwan strait this
year
since their missile launches beijing has
taken an irresponsible step of a
different kind
blinken says china is using pelosi's
visit to taiwan as a pretext to
disregard existing treaties they've also
suspended all climate cooperation with
the united states
the world's largest carbon emitter is
now refusing to engage on combating the
climate crisis
in response to china's military drills
the pentagon has ordered a u.s aircraft
carrier to remain in the waters near
taiwan it says the uss ronald reagan and
the ships in her strike group will stay
in the area
to monitor the situation
the u.s policy
was for 50 years engagement with china
that's over now
china is seen as a big danger from the
united states point of view this is
quite a dramatic change a sentiment
echoed by conservative media in the u.s
tensions still rising around taiwan
china halting some ties with you we need
to be strong that's what china
understands it's not words it's not
press releases it's actual strength and
presence in the region
a delicate balancing act for washington
and its long-standing policy of
strategic ambiguity the practice of
being intentionally ambiguous on the
status of taiwan which china sees as a
breakaway province it's going to
continue
we're going to
we're going to rub up against each other
the chinese and us are going to rub up
against each other not just in the
military realm but in the economic realm
it'll be a whole range of of issues a
new kind of cold war between two
superpowers
let's get the latest from our
correspondent tao tsun han in taipei
hello tao so taiwan's premier has
accused beijing of disrupting peace in
the region what more did he say
yes eddie um taiwan's premier sue also
called on beijing not to flex its
military muscles he said these words in
an information security meeting because
there are not only military exercises
around taiwan inside there are also
ongoing cyber attacks from china and
we're seeing a lot of rumors and
disinformation online he said these are
all part of china's psychological
warfare campaign in response he said
taiwan will expand the scope of the ban
on chinese-made information and
communication products to the public
sector and he urged the public and
private sectors to work together to
defend themselves against china strong
words there how are the drills going
today and how is taipei responding to
them
taiwanese officials said this morning
that they have detected several groups
of chinese aircraft ships and drones
operating around the taiwan strait
conducting joint air and sea exercises
to simulate attacks on taiwan's main
island
and according to the latest report and
photos released by the chinese army its
closest
worship is less than 12 kilometers from
taiwan's main island this is the first
time the chinese military has been so
close to taiwan at the same time the
taiwanese army monitored the situation
closely and deployed their most
cutting-edge defense system and weapons
to counter the threat
so is there any end in sight to these
drills
well
it was said originally to be the coming
monday august the 8th but the chinese
authorities announced on the 6th that
they are going to conduct live fire
shooting drills for another 10 days in
the southern waters of the yellow sea
and also another two near the buoy high
see till september these areas are very
close to south korea and is seen as
sending a warning to the u.s military
bases in south korea which might send
help to taiwan one military exercise
after another is clear that china is
trying to change the status quo of this
area and the military exercises could
become a new normal
uw's south sudan in taipei thank you
you